so you've got a on a particle so that's
the P in the in the question you've got
a platica P and it's a kilogram where's
a kilogram body it's suspended from AP
and BP so if peas in the middle you've
got AP and BP hanging somewhere up above
it right AP and BP they could be rods or
strings or any or cables or whatever
they have this ratio on place say yeah
we're gonna join in a second um ap forms
an angle with the ceiling like that and
then we have to show all of it now maybe
you don't quite have in your head what
on earth is going on so let me help you
i raided the test faculty for this here
we go now I exaggerated this a little
bit it's not quite three to two but it's
close enough okay so here these are
methods that work in there I don't
happen to actually this is probably more
like your company um you've got an
object right the particle of some mass
and it's suspended okay now you can see
these could be rigid things or as you
can see flexible things they get to a
point where they're not moving anymore
okay
now think about that think that don't
say it but think back to Newton's laws
of motion and what this means about the
forces okay just think about that for a
second so here is the picture right
you've got this thing it's suspended
from the ceiling you know these things
here about the geometry of it right and
this question down here and I'll unpack
what this language means in a second
this question here is all about saying
whoops I'm terrible
this question is all that saying alright
now I'm gonna ask you to help me
actually verbally write this object is
not moving anymore so it is experiencing
constant velocity which means what about
the forces okay they're balanced or
there is a net force of C they poked me
in the same thing okay now you guys know
because there's a force acting on you
just like me is acting on this and
acting like progressively tire arms
there's a force on this that's acting
downwards namely gravity okay but if
it's not moving that must mean is also a
force that's acting upward right now
where is that force coming from answer
it's coming from these strings so each
of these strings is pulling upward on
the mouse okay now because of the
arrangement of the the lengths of these
and also the angles that are formed here
the force that's being exerted by each
of the strings or AP and BP is different
okay
now why do you think this might matter
like working out it saw me a question
like this well might this be relevant
where do you have like things in real
life that are suspended that hang that
you know it really really matters and
you want to make sure they don't yeah
yeah yeah and anything that's hanging up
like that the thing that's most recently
in my mind is not that long ago I drove
over something that looks like this okay
so this this is the anzac bridge right
now just think right in fact this is not
that different you've got these two
things here that are meant to be your
anchors for this whole situation and
then it have all of these kings of all
different lengths their ratios are all
different to each other they are clearly
not all exerting the same amount of
force upward to hold on the bridge bump
in place right now if you're an engineer
you wanna know how much tension is
required of those cables to actually
keep your bridge market right it's
incredible feat of Engineering
this is one it's a Manor so you've got a
rough idea now let's draw this thing
right so I'll show you one more time
here's what I would model your drawing
on okay give me a ceiling make it
horizontal and then place on it
ap and baby
sad actually this is my life this is AP
over here such that ap is inclined 30
degrees and give me something roughly
like this ratio three to two okay I
think this is actually roughly two to
one but you get the idea you make your
drawing and then we're gonna put some
things on it make a big drawing by the
way cuz it's gonna get really busy
really fast
this diagram and how I got it from all
of here okay there's still some bits of
here I haven't put on it so you've got
the suspension from the ceiling you can
see how tried to do this as roughly
roughly three to two okay but that's not
the most important part of diagrams just
songs it's even begin the realm of
possibility I haven't labeled them as
three and two why not because I don't
know what their actual length on it
could be thirty seven minutes twenty
centimeters on three meters and 20
meters whatever so just leaving them
filing your way now this video ap is
inclined thirty degrees to this ceiling
so you have to be very careful with the
language you write so when you say
incline 30 degrees to or from you have
to think about how this is oriented and
then use that as your starting point
okay so here is the ceiling okay and
it's horizontal and then I've incline 30
degrees downwards okay because it's
suspended so has to be going down has to
be going clockwise around the edge
equalize your suspension okay so I've
gone from horizontal downwards so be
very careful because you'll have these
functions very cool as well so just to
recap boys no pie okay
show you that sine of this angle in
human now think that question about
stone for convenience they label this
alpha so maybe you want to show this
side that angle sine alpha is 3 over 4
okay look it's a triangle they want us
to do is sign so where did you buy it
link first okay so I'm gonna perfect
it's not my neighborhood so I don't know
the other many choices so I'm gonna go
here so now there's what I'm trying to
get
a baby right son of a beep any hood well
what's the site that matches anything
it's a his equal to it right so what's
the corresponding ratio sign all the
other line area over it cool so fast
very good now have you looked if you
know what sign that it is okay and look
at the result you're trying to prove so
when you think this rabbit comes out
from what how many pulls out remember I
got signed an EP or the rate of left so
all I really need to do is yeah my
across now I've written it in this way
because you know what sign thing is I'll
just point out because I think this
seems really obvious but I've only just
learnt it to me you've never learned it
before you though you're the ratio side
or at the ratio side it's just the
division sign without the line right
that's that's what it is so that's why
you can fight it as is 3 or 2 yeah so if
a lot of countries like you mean they
don't actually have that division side
they just use the colon because they're
like yeah it's just we just don't or
you're white because that's redundant
that mathematicians get rid of
redundancy so you can see AV on VP is
just a piece here yeah so I'm ready this
is my 3 on 2 this is my heart so there's
the result now this next part you've um
not heard this phrase for a real while
or you know have this word rather
resolve we talked about resolving
velocities and accelerations back in
projectile motion do you remember that
we talked about in resolving you had an
object in your life blue okay I
projected off at some angle and
resolving what is resolving me in this
context
okay so there's like a horizontal
component and it is a vertical component
why did it deal with why don't I want to
separate out one thing into Institute
what was the point of that
okay fantastic feel like right this die
is expensing gravity and this guy's
experiencing nothing there's constant
that velocity okay so I've separated
these out in this context to help me
work out how the forces relate and thus
it the situation is much the same over
here okay so have a look the first force
I can actually draw on there and it is
already up down left right and I don't
have to do anything with it
it's just a lot drawn there in the first
places what's missing it's grabbing it
right okay now if you remember force is
mass times acceleration right mass times
acceleration so therefore you've got a
mass one kilogram
what's the acceleration going downwards
yeah it's uh identified right there you
go okay so it's 9.8 so going down with
I'm gonna write this as M G get used to
writing that you got a vitamin water
mass times gravity going down so this is
equal to in our context and I'm gonna
write it as 1 times it's 9.8 okay I
guess I really should say it's actually
negative because it's going down that
make sense I can't by the way I can
leave off if I've got the errors well
then they tell me direction which is the
same something they need to tell me so
frequently you will see diagram
and the nun is just telling you
magnitude it's the error that tells you
which way this thing is facing that make
sense